Midnight Rider weighs 25 and a half tons.
That's the equivalent of 10 to 12 super stretch limousines.
It's 70 feet long, 14 feet high, and eight and a half feet wide.
It has 22 wheels, 440 horsepower.
It takes a crew of five, has a bar, a forward lounge, an observation lounge...
...and a rear lounge to carry 40 passengers.
And we are very pleased to have it in the Guinness Book of World Records.
Well, we weren't originally trying to obtain a world record.
That kind of came about as we were in the planning stages...
...of building the Midnight Rider.
It took us seven years to build it...
...and we built it in the household by ourselves, four people basically.
And we wanted people to be able to travel together in groups again...
...at a slower pace...
...like they used to do in the railroad days.
I grew up reading the Guinness Book of World Records.
Never in my wildest dreams would I have thought we'd be in it...
...as the heaviest limousine in the world.
And we are just so excited that that has happened.